all right Monday night in Kona Jason
Lester at Jason Lester on Twitter calm
and rich roll here we're at Kona natural
foods with a little shop here for the
ultraman Ground Zero Training Center it
was known as a chez Jason luster so we
don't need too many things that we
thought we would come into the local
natural market here see we can find
talked little nutrition I'm gonna
interview I'm gonna interview rich about
why he puts healthy living foods into my
body so that I could feel healthy and
vibrant everybody has different
nutrition plans avocados
rich is big on avocados he's the only
guy that I know that will eat like two
and three
avocado sandwiches at night
why this is Apple bananas Apple bananas
ah this is the we might not want to show
them that I know because if we're
letting the secret out of the eye now
you're gonna let the melio this secret
weapon of all endurance athletes you
promise me that you're going to just
keep that between us
yeah oh so you're going to tell them
okay all right so Makkah as rich calls
it Dakine or prana these juice for our
Vitamix --is in the morning just no
mason mainly for flavor for flavor and
stuff like that is the one thing that
everybody needs to know about juice is
despite what a lot of the labels that
say about super high antioxidants or etc
every juicer you buy in the store is
either pasteurized or flash pasteurized
and what that means is it basically
destroys a large percentage of the
nutritional value of basically every
juice you're going to buy so I don't
drink too much store-bought Jesus I'd
rather make my own juice that's not
pasteurized but you know still drink
some of this just for flavor purposes
but just don't be under the impression
that you're getting all the antioxidants
and things
but some of these products advertised
well these are organic juices so these
are good you know I always choose
organic but you know most juice is
basically sugar that's what it is right
soy products I try to avoid soy products
we all have them from time to time and
I'll eat tofu but I try to not eat too
much toys another secret weapon that
Ritchie introduced and these these
people also make coconut coconut milk
kefir tastes like try this stuff really
good for you super nutritious and
detoxifying sprouted wheat bagels why
sprouted because the more that
the wheat is refined the less nutritious
it is for you so I try to eat mostly
gluten-free products but I'll have some
wheat but if you're going to get wheat
products you should try to discuss the
whole grains the sprouted grains is
there less refined and more than
nutritional values we've killed like
about four of those bags in the last
week and we're really big on hemp bread
all the arrows are all starts at
gluten-free type bread products which
are good they're either made with rice
or spelt
I'll do I'll do ice read find flowers
that we intend to cause inflammation
which impedes recovery right 182 here's
the gluten-free cereal that I am big on
it looks like they are here we go here's
wheat free one more leg course likes
it's gluten free because it's a
let's talk soups one of our other black
beans ate tons of black beans super high
in protein so I polish off like four or
five of these a week and we're also big
on organic gluten-free pasta oh this is
pasta that's made with brown rice
instead of a wheat products so it's
gluten free basically tastes almost
exactly the same and you don't get that
sort of heavy feeling after you eat it
like you gotta take it now so a great
source of replenishing your glycogen
stores complex carbohydrate this stuff
is the bomb quinoa is an excellent
source of carbohydrate hand it's a good
protein source actually so this has its
e unser vine which is a quarter cup has
six grams of protein for so for those of
you who don't think plant-based foods
are good sources of protein check this
out
you can also use this at the breakfast
room
very
blueberries and coconut milk there's a
whole well Bragg's is a good product
they also make something called our
Bragg's Liquid aminos oh it's right here
so check this out this stuff basically
tastes like soy sauce but super-high in
amino acid so when you're eating a
plant-based diet you want to make sure
you're getting a complete amino acid
profile so you can build those proteins
and rebuild your muscles
this works great as like a salad
dressing and it's like a protein
supplement basically so Rybak's is a
really good brand it's already product
haha yes so basically what this is is
essentially plant-based mayonnaise so
it's egg free dairy free do you want to
give them a little bit secret on what
you do it that's the eat it by the
spoonful
at night so I actually think it tastes
better than mayonnaise and what it is is
it's made with
instead of dairy products
no eggs delicious and dairy-free
a good source of a good source of good
fats that are good for you I polish one
of these off on like a week every week
so he like slaps gobs of it on sprouts
is intro to yet we're cool almond butter
there's a question for you crunchy or
creamy
that's our secret - on the bike day -
ultraman butter sandwiches
it sounds good oh you know what we need
what's that coconut water coconut water
how about here
got it here the can unfortunately we
don't have it in the cart why do we like
coconut water coconut water is a good
source of electrolytes after you train
will actually go grab something I think
we're in here and why there just be coke
on so everyone gets by and check out of
home here I got something funny for you
guys I'm like rich we don't have coconut
water here in the carton he goes why
don't you just go up and just grab a
coconut out of the tree and just pop a
hole in it and just drink it how about
how about we treat ourselves to a calm
future yeah
yeah GT Dave began following kombucha 95
after his mother's success from drinking
it during her battle with breast cancer
he's a young kid young guy started how
about some flax oil we got tons of it
already but stuff is great
how about hemp oil I got that to a boil
we put hemp oil and flax oil after shake
for your mega threes and essential fatty
acids good fats
especially when you're an endurance
athlete it's all about training your
engine to burn fat
that can be your friend
smart about the passenger you let's talk
about hemp protein I like hemp protein
because in your body
and speaking of recovery let's go eat so
hey I'm here thanks for stopping by with
us again guys we will continue to bring
you with us along our journey to the
ultraman World Championships yeah let's
go the farmers market in the next couple
days and we'll bring you guys down there
and show you how we load up on fresh
mangoes bananas roll dog we're out of
here it's time to go grub thanks for
stopping by we will catch up to you guys
uliana
Aloha